you know love has taken me to some  pretty dark places but Los Angeles has  got to be as dark as it gets your  followers see an image and imagine  you're on top of the world what they  don't see is the effort you're putting  into this fantasy you're hiding behind  this facade but why you tell yourself  you live off the earth that deep breath  isn't you savoring the gluten-free  muffin you're preening your ego and  breaking an intermittent fast if it was  actually a story of substance I could  forgive you for writing a screenplay  instead of a book but you're not writing  anything groundbreaking you tell  yourself you are but you're not see  that's the thing about LA everyone is  pretending to be somebody they're not hi  can I get a name for the order yeah I'm  will  you